you
[Music]
hi I'm Nathalie my diamond sheathing 14k
my my character on Game of Thrones this
season this she's just very much more of
the same in the sense of she's
supporting Daenerys in her breasts to be
queen if I could date someone in the
Seven Kingdoms I feel like I would
probably day like Robb Stark or
something he kind of fundamentally is a
good guy you know he was avenging his
father and those kind of morals and
married the woman he loved despite what
his farm he told him he's kind of does
what he believes it and I might do that
personally my ideal they had it really
nice having pleased but it's like
talking to somebody new so having dinner
or just meeting for lunch or something I
think the one piece of advice for dating
like listen give would probably be don't
date a guy who's intimidated by your
power because she's a very powerful
woman I would definitely take that
advice because there's a lot of guys who
are intimidated by women's power
I need someone who is gonna encourage
you to exercise that kind of grow